so listen I got a bunch of questions for
you uh if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and
why oh man I would I would actually like
them to watch The Beekeeper first cuz it
is the most unhinged character I've ever
played um and I guess after they see if
they've never seen anything else and
they see this first everything else will
be a breeze and much easier pill to
swallow but this guy is just Derek's out
of his mind uh a lot of fun to play a
lot of fun what do you think it is I
love watching Jason saan punch people in
the face yeah what do you think it is
about Jason that people love watching
him punch people he does it so well he
does it so well he does it so well you
know I think there's something about
Jason I feel like that he has this you
you just you root for him and even if
he's like morally maybe not in the right
sometimes and he goes about things in
the wrong way in his characters he plays
you just really root for him there's
something about he's kind of like the
underdog even though he just kicks ass
always but there's something about him
that you just want him you want him to
win no for sure I also think that with
this film uh I wish more people like
older people would be able to see the
first 10 or 15 minutes because it does a
really good job at explaining how people
can get screwed over by scammers well it
starts out as a PSA that's what the idea
originally was for this movie it was
just a PSA for older people to not get
scammed and then snowballed and then
Ryder went crazy but this was actually a
government funded PSA it's not true uh
but no but ites it does do it yeah it
really does and actually I have a my my
great grandma was scammed in a similar
way they didn't get to her bank account
and take all the money in the world from
her but they uh they got her good and
it's uh it's really unfortunate that
that it's a thing no I I actually
thought that I I said to David I thought
at the beginning is a really good job at
explaining people how quickly someone
can get take anyway so my my people at
collider uh reminded me of something and
I wanted to read it so I don't screw
this up do you know how you've become
well-loved on Tik Tok due to your older
clips of you hosting SNL Hunger Games
yes yeah I'm not really on I'm not on
Tik Tok and I I don't really go on
social media all that often uh but my
friends have sent me multiple links to
all these clips that are coming up and
getting dredged up from the past and uh
look man it's cool it's cool it's cool
to be a part of that and you know
you never know what will become big and
why and the internet works in mysterious
ways so it's it's fun to be a part of
the Ze guys in that way right now oh
100% I'm also not on Tik Tok but I when
some of my interviews get spread around
it's it's good for the site it's you
know what I mean I'm I'm hey it's great
I'm here for it I'm here for it so
obviously need to touch on uh um
Freddy's because it was a huge hit uh
when did you realize oh wait a minute
this might be like a huge movie honestly
ly not until it was like out and we were
seeing how many people were going to to
watch it um you know Freddy's it's such
an amazing world and game and the fan
base is rabid and we were excited to
make a movie that they would enjoy and
that they could really you know sink
their teeth into but I think that what
we didn't quite estimate was how many
how many people would come and see it
that maybe weren't even fans of the game
um and it was great it's such a cool
movie it's such a cool world to play in
and uh I'm I'm hopeful and looking
forward to to making more of them so
we'll see when that announcement comes
and stuff but uh I can't wait to get
back into that yeah I wanted to ask you
uh has Blum housee asked you to save any
dates in
2024 not exactly but it looks good yeah
it looks good I I spoke to Ryan and
other people at Blum house I'm like how
have you not announced the release date
and the green light of the sequel when
it did insane numbers yeah we're all
we're all patiently waiting I think I
mean look I think that they they have a
lot to figure out as far as is where to
take the story cuz there's a lot of
options based in the various formats of
the game and story and lore so I think
they're kind of like trying to nail down
exactly which Avenue they're going to
proceed down and then uh and then we'll
get to shooting do you know what else
you're working on in 2024 not yet no not
yet it's kind of I mean based on like
where the strike was and everything last
year things are really slowing down so
now it's kind of picking back up again
so I'm uh I'm excited to get some stuff
lined up but as of now just looking
forward to uh to to Freddy sequel at
some point this year hopefully on that
note I will say you were fantastic in
this and uh I wish you nothing but the
best thanks man you
too